well there's some breakthrough
technology that could help those
struggling with hair
loss good evening tonight I'm going to
sound like a
drunk check your panties about
175,000 rice I think that was supposed
to be
pantries I couldn't warn you before I
saw it and I couldn't warn you Eric I'm
so sorry about 175,000 rice and slow
cookers are being recalled due to Fire
and electric shock hazards let's take a
live look through the steamship Grill
Harbor Cam the COO is back arriving from
Port Angeles with another Bo boatload
of a
buttload a boatload of
tourists ready to enjoy the long
weekend young people are now taking
themselves out on elaborate solo day
dates and I'm going to be careful here
because this trend is called Master
dating Tik Tock is all over this
trend I can't do because it doesn't just
include dates it might also involve
buying yourself some nice gifts take
yourself to dinner
first is it off or is it on do you need
me to turn you
on no I'm coming to use my microphone
you not need the microphone I turned it
on that was so
creepy are
you go on finish up Sarah
I this he loses his mind sometimes go on
it's all good well it's behind you was
very nice of you Larry just trying to
help to you're a giver gosh what a great
guy my butt's wet oh my God it's so
wet okay oh is there holes in the bottom
Oh I thought it had a thing no my butt's
wet but it's fine the dog in Thailand is
certainly giving new meaning to the
phrase doggy St doggy paddle excuse me
he was found swimming 135 mil off the
shore of Thailand near an oil rig
workers for spider than I
don't I know there's no way around it
they they little gorgeous Ginger nut kid
Ginger nut that's said with enormous
affection you can't say that some of my
best friends of red heads including
George's gorgeous husband thank you very
muching he doesn't mind being called
ginger nuts don't you worry about that
see there you go Ginger nuts maybe you
just don't have any in your life it's
just one it's one nut not
two now extinctions I don't have to tell
you have been part of the Natural
History of the World for Millennia um
and uh man-made extinctions have even
happened before I guess we hunted the
dildo into Extinction um but the dodo
rather forgive me um I'm I'm having
trouble with my words today yes looks
very good all right Friday well thank
you it's Friday what are those wow that
I'm exhausted you can see I didn't know
You' be able to see him oh my
gosh I didn't know you could see over
this a little charging this is p
charging only the only plug is over here
I don't have one by my I thought it was
a large mous family I thought it was a
mouse for the computer happy
Friday like this like bigger my God are
those yours Jim
time now for one more thing I got to pee
I got to
pee you're on the
[Music]
[Laughter]
air Greg
Greg yeah every morning she's like I
can't breathe don't take my inhaler away
I really need that thing I mean the
other day April had to you know give her
some mouth to mouth to keep it going
proba really odd it was a life saving
move though nothing more is video ay we
just got a really bizarre look into his
Fantasy Life sorry April I'm pretty sure
that didn't happen I'm pretty sure I'd
remember that oh you'd
remember oh and the last thing was um
Olivia gond that it says that I want to
eat her [__] gond I've never said that
in my life to her I would never do that
I'm halfly married I've got more than
enough to eat at home thank you very
much anything
that Cadence was so quick on here all
look at that sweat down there lot of
Sweat and Tears for a great cause in the
hellberg sport TR so I'm getting I'm
getting wet talking to you no no no it's
totally fine there are always very good
reasons to watch our show two very good
reasons today stages is not painful so
it is not easy for a person to know
they've got cancer that is why I
encourage men H to suck those titties
and I encourage
women is it embarrassing you don't suck
a titty why do you suck you've got to
suck
something if you pick out two matching
heads you win and cuz your your head is
on just La some of my balls no your your
head's there oh I can see my head on a
ball we pick one one of your balls you
pick a ball or two of your balls no pick
one first one ball okay whose head on L
is on your ball very good okay pick
another ball okay now what happens
please be two balls please be two balls
I've got Sylvia and Lisa on your
balls you have to be really careful out
there you do we've had sex six rather
consecutive days of R did I okay all
right that was a Freudian slip but we're
going to pretend like we didn't hear
it Chris the middle piece of the toilet
C actually has a use if used properly
wait what is I have never ever seen it
used that way and it makes so much sense
does it's for boys oh because that area
is very dirty I never thought oh Lisa
has I have been using it me too I've
been using it in I've been using it
wrong all these years well you wouldn't
use it like that it's for it's for men
now Doug who an engineer please I don't
know a Jacksonville man just won a
million doll jack off jackpot from a
scratch off where he bought the winning
ticket that's aeed six Welcome Back Time
right now 555 it seems the Christmas
shopping bug is hitting a lot of people
and some animals that's right check this
out it's a very curious beaver a
Maryland Sheriff's Office says they got
a call from a local store saying the
beaver was wreaking havoc in the
Christmas
section to see that while the Sheriff's
Office later tweeted that the beaver was
was rescued and after long pet sessions
apparently was released back into the
wild a lot of beavers in the news lately
did we have a beaver in the news
yesterday or the day before he's going
to the aquarium I think oh yes Jinx
there's apparently they're the most
popular creatures right now this time of
year Beaver breeding those little guys
are cute and cuddly looking the Beavers
I've seen are bigger and not yeah and
they don't look as friendly so I I don't
know maybe I've seen my beavers in the
wrong place
[Laughter]
moving
on yes weather time let's uh yeah yeah
this afternoon not too bad uh uh
temperatures in the 50s and 60s let's go
to the maps there we go that's right and
you know Damon you were telling us uh
you have gas and you are you big of a
cooking not gas oh boy
that's you have a gas
stove are you able to get through this
weather in the cast now you
guys
this is what you've been missing I told
him that it was my first day anchoring
and the bird's laughing at me
yes oh my
gosh what do we have here uh we have
here is called a laughing okay as you
can
hear they are native to
Australia and you can find them at all
habitat what you're hearing right now is
a territorial call okay and this call is
primarily DUS and Dawn now these little
babies are so
overwhelmed that they've started wearing
your clothes that's cute [__] get out
of my
pants there you
okay coming up the Obesity warning to
parents we're going to speak to
Australia's top doct Lisa and Deb we
meet the family desperately trying to
bring their Pooch back here's some other
great town names Lititz oh it's litz
l i can Overlook it at least this one
time Nick I will well maybe next
Wednesday I'll have to remove you there
Nick I just didn't want to be the person
who's like I really don't want to be the
person who bre it that Wednesday's going
to be uh in the
80s well you got to find you there hey
come on man here you go get the song
playing for [__] sake excuse me I just
said it on air Tom we
uh good morning to is 5:00 right now on
your Wednesday morning thanks for
joining us I'm Kate Merill I mean
I'm
God I am Kate Merill that is Chris
McKinnon and it is a Wednesday Danielle
because somebody needs to get some sleep
keny should give me back my hat your hat
is that yours do it look like a boy hat
it's not it's mine it's yours I think he
looks like a country superstar in it
like Kenny chesne he does except he
should take his shirt off he's going to
it's coming up it's coming up we promise
did we lose a camera at that Park before
didn't somebody fall in the water with a
camera was it there yeah I don't
remember that oh it wasn't a wave pool
yeah the wave pool the waves came in and
then you looked real pretty my what it
is a what she talking so loud you can
hear her anyway mid is it on now oh no I
think they wanted it
off just kidding just kidding oh just
going the
way I was kidding Jenny's feelings are
hurt where's she going now is there oh
she's leaving she's going outside well
is traffic
okay that door doesn't slam coming up in
10 minutes we've got people from the
Alberta Masters games coming in talking
about how if you're over 30 you compete
in in a wide range of sports in Alberta
for the first time they brought a pickle
ball they brought a pickle ball and a
racket we should have play some pickle
ball well they just brought one so we
would have to throw it at each other but
I'm in you can play with yourself oh oh
oh so was raining outside and scattered
showers across the city 12° as I feel
very warm all of a sudden
sweating What's happen TR I'm trying to
move on and it'll be cooler and wet
today just just going to play
[Laughter]
[Music]
with going on and on and I am getting
tired yeah you TR to
crucify all the good ins you
going I already di well a Georgia woman
had a good laugh when deiry Queen made a
pretty significant error on her birthday
cake now take a look here this is the
cake in question she's a she's a big
Moana fan the Disney character they
thought it was Moana they why My Little
Pony on
it nice little portable water fountain
for your puppy dog so gravity fed you
tip it up Che it works yeah you can
drink from that car new Straight from
Amazon has been used I don't know have a
drink no I don't think so demonstrate
how it works really off no it's not it's
just water and so you can't find
it why did you do that why did you do
that it's not like hey hey it's
s Everyone in mckin is dead the
temperature the the the heat index right
now in McKenna is 10,000 what is that
10,15 Sylvia just went
o o it's a bit
happening are you ready car I don't know
that I can deal with that do did you
bring your rub of gloves this morning oh
my
God brace
position mate this is serious is this
serious all eyes right now on Hillary
Clinton or EXC hurricane Hillary let me
get that right as it continues to track
towards the United States here towards
California Reynold and he says what's
really long Harden stuffs new
zealanders Primary
School oh come on last night's
dismantling of Ohio State by the Gators
proving the SEC is indeed the toughest c
conference in the country according to
Friday's Atlanta Journal Constitution
the state of Virginia is going to seek
to indict dick dick not finished
Saturday's game against Detroit an MRI
reveals a bulging dick this in his lower
back today he said he was deeply sorry
describing the breach as of an
in words out
[__] well apologies uh for that
confusion that was our correspondent
Charlotte gallager she's monitoring
what's been happening there please what
was the worst Christmas gift you ever
got worst Christmas gift I ever got yeah
come
on oh no I'm sure there have been a few
probably the ugly sweater uhhuh I got an
interesting one from my mom one year it
was a pair of on wait hold let me let me
before you go is your mom watching this
morning probably not okay then go ahead
with the story it was a pair of
underwear that said call me in glitter
on the back from my
mom I wish you guys could see Mel's face
with that one she's just being
thoughtful well she is and she wants you
to call when you get home so when the
last thing when you get undressed and
put your Jamies on you know it's just a
little reminder right there in handy cuz
everybody needs underwear right and you
know that reminder to call your mom
sometimes you need to have message on
your underp wow that's pretty
spectacular we have new information now
also on the plane crash KTV has just
learned the names of the four pilots who
were on board the flight they are
Captain Su Ting Wong
we to low holy fuk and bang ding ow I'm
WR TV's Rafael Sanchez and these are
your
Le n have a national Awkward Moment day
I think we pretty much had several of
those today so as as we go out and just
enjoy every awkward moment I'm sorry but
awkward moment awkward spelled wrong
goat gone viral take a look at this a
goat with a literal ponytail oh my
goodness what is happening that I'm so
confed so many I have so many questions
this is a family
show your head's not supposed to be
there you little
goat yeah stick to the script people
okay let me tell the people what
happened the animal was walking behind a
pony on the farm which was swishing its
tail around and as you can see the hair
got caught in its horns oh the owner
says neither of the animals were hurt in
this but it was not easy to take apart
so um the winter is not quite done with
this and this last winter weekend and my
clicker doesn't want to advance anything
magic is it the leprechaun I think it is
they're being mischievous all right let
me try this clicker and see if the
leprechaun didn't get that one here's
your exclusive AC weather now I'm double
fisted in a different way for St
Patrick's Day Mile with a shower and 62
for your high tomorrow Breezy mostly
sunny skies and 54 Sunday that's the day
windchills near that freezing Mark 43
for your high but when you're waking up
at 7:00 a.m. I'm on the air Sunday tune
in so I'm not alone windchills just in
the teens Monday a nice start to Spring
a high of 53 upper 50s on Tuesday
looking good 59 Wednesday mild some
sunshine 60 Thursday partly sunny skies
and 57 and to another woman who likes to
be double fisted in a different way I
think Jess
she means beer she means beer uh guys
she means beer don't put me on YouTube
My
God sharing the sound of a black hole
and it's kind of creating a buzz on
social media apparently so take a
listen definitely sounds like there's
some ghosts in there well I want to know
who is making that sound or what the
ghost you're right
and the Goblin the ghosts and goblins
the haunted house that's what it sounds
like NASA shared the noise from a Galaxy
cluster which is about 240 million light
years away from Earth so no worries
it'll take them a long time to get here
to get us scientists say that the black
hole sends out pressure waves that cause
ripples in hot gas which can be
translated into these notes these tones
and sounds so gas can make
sounds yep sometimes
that is true a look outside across
Southwest Florida and everywhere that
you look
absolutely
did I'm sorry there are baby goats right
now in the studio and I am not going to
be able to do
this all right we're going to try our
hardest you guys blue skies across
Southwest Florida right now temperatures
we are ranging in the up 80s right
now that one was Greg upper 80s right
now in lots of sunshine some ' 90s on
the board right now as well already
feeling like oh great the Frat Boys
showed up why are they looking at me you
need something bro that's how they talk
in frat language they say bro it's Rad
Brad it's probably his name his name is
probably Brad oh my God could the wind
just give up I'm sorry Lord oh okay
stare at me that helps could you just
stop stop with the wind Lord I feel like
he's just stop you know he's just
standing up there going you didn't go to
church on
Easter oh good Chad showed up God I need
to get better at liking people oh I'm
sorry I took your name in
vain Lord help me ready we'll just do
that the wind doesn't want to cooperate
we'll just do that that's fine you like
that I don't 3 2 1 I quit conditions
were so treacherous in Christ church
this morning that even those taking to
the streets were finding it
slippery at some point the officers
apparently opened fire one of them
striking lyans no officers were injured
the Ohio Bureau of criminal
investigation is handling the
case get you informed on RAB vaccination
clinic hello there goes violet ready so
you go one
two